When we refer to the sensitivity of people
to different wavelengths of light we use a
unit called lumens, and lumens are defined.
So at the wavelength 555 nanometers, which
is green, one watt of light creates a sensation
of 683 lumens.
At a wavelength of 500 nanometers—which
is blue—a one watt light source would only
get a sensation of 220 lumens.
So it is the same amount of electronic energy,
but if it is concentrated at that wavelength,
it produces a smaller sensation to the human
observer and if we had one watt of electronic
energy at 800 nanometers it would produce
zero lumens—we can’t see it, it results
in no sensation at all.
So we can look at the human luminosity response
and there are two of these: there is our night
time response which is called the scotopic
response and a day time response, the photopic
response.
This is our overall sensation to light at
a particular wavelength, and it is clear that
at night we are much more sensitive to shorter
wavelengths, the bluer colours, than we are
during the day time.
We talked before that humans have got three
types of cone cells in the backs of our eyes,
the short medium and long wavelength cones.
Because we have three of them we are referred
to as being trichromats, tri meaning we have
three color sensors in our eyes.
Humans are somewhat unusual amongst mammals
in having three color receptors; most mammals
only have two.
And this graph shows the response of the short
and long wavelength cones for a typical mammal.
Many birds are tetrachromats; that means that
they have four different types of cones cells
and the response of the bird’s cone cells
are shown here.
Now clearly there must be some evolutionary
advantage for birds to have four cone cells.
It gives them a better ability to discriminate
colors.
We can argue that perhaps for the other mammals
there is no need to have three cone cells,
two is enough.
Not all humans have perfect trichromatic vision.
Many humans suffer from color blindness and
I am one of those people.
I suffer from a red, green color deficiency
and what that means for me is that the sensitivity
of my medium wavelength cone is shifted a
bit to the right, so my medium wavelength
cone response overlaps my long wavelength
cone response.
So the two cone responses are almost equal
and that makes it very hard for me to distinguish
reds from greens.
Now this is a hereditary defect, this particular
gene is on the tip of the X chromosome and
is passed from males to males via females.
Color blindness is reasonably prevalent in
the community, particularly amongst males,
and the particular defect that I have is shared
by six per cent of men in the population.
It is quite difficult to try and explain to
people what it is like to be color blind.
This slide is trying to illustrate to somebody
with normal color vision how the world looks
with these different types of color defects,
whether someone is missing their L cone, their
M cone or their S cone.
So here we have the spectrum of the illuminant
and in this case this is the spectrum of the
noon day sun as measured on the surface of
the earth, so it is not the smooth black body
curve that we looked at earlier, it has got
lumps and bumps in it due to absorption of
parts of the spectrum by molecules in the
atmosphere and here is the luminance of the
light that is being reflected from the brick.
And that is obtained from the reflectance
function for the red brick multiplied by the
illuminance spectrum.
So the light from the sun reflected from the
brick has got this particular luminance spectrum.
The final step is to apply a number of filters
or response functions to the incoming luminance
and in our eye we apply three different response
functions.
So there are three different versions of M;
the response function.
So let’s consider firstly the blue response
function; so we take the incoming luminance
and we filter it with the response of the
blue cone and we can see that here.
Now the total response of the cone is the
integral of the luminance multiplied by the
response function, and that is the area underneath
the curve, that is what is shown here as the
solid mass of blue.
So the area underneath this curve is the total
amount of energy, it is the total response
of the blue cone in the retina for this particular
incoming luminance.
Similarly for the green cone, we apply the
green cones response function, its own version
of M of lambda and then we integrate the area
underneath the curve, and that is what is
shown here as a solid mass of green and we
do exactly the same thing for the red cone.
We have taken an incoming luminance spectrum,
applied three filters to it, integrated the
response of those filters and the results
are three numbers an amount of red, green
and blue.
This process sounds complicated, but it has
done a very clever thing.
If we consider that the spectrum of illuminance,
that is, the spectrum of the light that is
entering out eyes from a particular object,
it says something about the material properties
of that object; an apple, for instance, is
red; a leaf of a plant is green.
All of these different objects in the world
have got a different spectrum.
But to describe a spectrum we need an infinite
number of numbers.
It is a continuous functional wavelength.
It is an infinite dimensional signal.
But by applying three spectral filters to
this incoming light and integrating the output
of the signal after it has passed to each
of these filters, we are left simply with
three numbers.
So we have reduced an infinite dimensional
signal simply to three numbers or to three
dimensions … performed a massive dimensionality
reduction.
A consequence of this dimensionality reduction
is the possibility of ambiguity; that is,
that there are an infinite number of different
luminance spectrum that will give exactly
the same values of R, G and B.
We refer to such spectra as metamers; that
is, different spectra that give you exactly
the same R, G and B value.
But clearly this is not a significant problem
in everyday life; it is not something that
we worry or stress about, so we have evolved
a good enough solution to the problem.
We can recognise objects by reducing the dimensionality
of the signals which indicate what they are
made of into just three quantities, three
numbers.